hi I'm Chet Haase an engineer on the
Android team at Google I do a bunch of
work on animations and I've done some
dead bytes in the past on ListView
animations and I got a request to show
how you might animate adding and
removing items from the ListView so
recently I did a talk with Tom Agee on
animations at Google i/o you might want
to check that out since it has some of
the content and related content as well
and one of the demos that I showed was
removing items from the ListView exactly
what people wanted I've tuned the code a
little bit to make it a little more
general purpose and we're going to show
a bit more about how it actually works
today so the idea with ListView removals
is that you're deleting an item there
maybe you want to swipe it out and the
demo that I have you swipe these items
out and then the swipe itself is
animated and after the item is removed
from the ListView the ListView collapses
the gap around that item and views move
in from the top or the bottom wherever
they need to and all of this is seamless
to the user it's kind of the effect and
the feel that you want with the ListView
but it may not be particularly obvious
how to do so so let's see how this
actually works today now one important
point that I should point out if you
look closely at the code in the Google
i/o version of this demo you'll see this
I was using a property called transient
state which was added in jellybean I've
actually removed that it's it's used
implicitly under the hood when you use a
view property animator but I'm not using
it explicitly in the demo code anymore
because I actually found a more general
purpose way of doing this animation so
it's a little more applicable to
different releases as well so let's see
how it works so if we take a look at the
code one important point and this is
right at the heart of why I don't need a
transient state anymore is that I'm
using a stable array adapter this is a
subclass of array adapter that I created
to return true for has stable IDs this
is a key element because I'm no longer
animating the views directly getting
information directly from the views and
then making sure that those views all
stay on the screen at the same time
that's dependent upon the jellybeans
capability of transient State instead I
am dependent upon the underlying array
adapter to have stable ID so that I can
count on those items actually being in
the same as changes in the array adapter
happen so I do that by returning true
there and when I get item ID I actually
get unique IDs as I process the array
and then one the only other custom thing
that happens in this array adapter is I
set a non touch listener because every
item in the view as its created I want
it to know where to go for its touch
events because I'm going to customize
that with some swiping behavior which
we'll see very soon so if we go back to
our activity class
here's that touch listener that we were
just talking about so the idea here is
that I want to note when the user clicks
down and I want to note when they sweat
left to right because I I want to first
detect when it's gone far enough that
we're actually in a swiping motion now
so I'm going to start animating that as
they move their finger so then I want to
position the view and I want to also set
the Alpha the view to make it disappear
more the closer to the edge of the
screen that it gets and then when they
actually let go with that item I want to
determine whether to snap the item back
or to animate it all the way off I
should point out that in the widgets
that we actually ship we use velocity
tracking which is a better way to do
this in general I'm using a simple
heuristic of how far have you moved
instead which works for the purposes the
demo I think a more full version of this
effect would actually use velocity
tracking instead so that as you lift it
off your finger as your sweat is swiping
to the right then the item would
actually animate at the same speed that
it was just moving which is a nicer
effect nevertheless a simple approach
here and also simple to change using
velocity instead so when the user
presses down if there's another item
pressing I'm not handling multi-touch
clicks here we're just making a simple
demo here so we return false we're not
going to handle this event otherwise we
set the value say okay we're now
tracking things and we're going to note
the initial version of the initial
location that they press down in so that
we know how far to move the item in
initial move events when there is a
subsequent move event here we get the
current location of that
and then we know how far the user has
moved the item in general and then we
also know whether to detect for swipe
slop which is basically how far they
moved head they moved past the point
where yes we we think it's not just an
error but we should actually start
swiping this thing out so you see a
little jump at the beginning as we
detect that is not just noise but
they're actually moving it far enough
for us to start swiping it away we tell
the ListView to disallow intercept touch
events because I don't want the ListView
doing its own thing with scrolling up
and down at the same time as I'm trying
to swipe items back and forth so when
you call this method and set it to true
then until the final up event from the
touch event processor then the items
have full control over here the ListView
will not get in your way
and then we tell the background
container to show the background we'll
get into this a little bit later this is
the detail about what exactly go we're
going to show behind the item as its
swiped away so if we're actually swiping
this thing then we're going to set the
translation X so we're going to move
this item back and forth according to
how far the users finger has moved and
we're going to set the Alpha we
basically want it to be the inverse of
how far away it is from wherever they
started so the closer they get to the
edge of the screen one way or the other
the more translucent it's going to be
the idea being that it's going to fade
out all the way by the time it gets off
the screen and then finally when the
user lifts up if they were swiping this
thing then we can find out how far they
swipe it whether they're going off the
screen to the left off the screen to the
right and then we can set the duration
based on that we're going to set the
duration based on how far they had left
to go to the edge of the screen whether
they're whether it's popping back into
place or actually popping all the way
off the screen we're going to set
enabled false on the ListView this
prevents the user from doing something
silly like actually scrolling and
flinging the ListView at the same time
as we're animating all the views into
place makes things look a little bit
more consistent and reasonable on the
screen and then we're going to set that
enabled to true when we're actually all
done with the animation there's two
animations that are going to kick in
here the first is that we're going to
animate the swipe out or the swipe back
and then if it was a swipe out then
we're going to run a following animation
which is going to animate the closure of
the gap that that item created when it
was removed from the list so we're going
to set the duration according that that
duration that we calculated before we're
going to animate alpha this is using a
view property animator which was API
that came in in 3.1 honeycomb 3.1 and
we're also going to animate translation
X to its end value either back all the
way on the screen or all the way off the
screen and then we're going to run oh
and action now this is API that came in
in jellybean so if you're writing for
jellybean and later that's fine if
you're writing for API for runtimes that
are earlier than jellybean you don't
have to use an end action here instead
you can set up a listener on the view
property animator and it's just a little
bit more code but it's effectively the
same thing
when the end of the animation happens
we're going to run this code so the
swipe has happened now we actually want
to animate the removal animate moving
the removing the gap in the ListView so
if we're actually removing the item if
it was swiped off then we're going to
animate removal here otherwise we're all
done and we're just going to restore the
values that we need so animate removal
is down here now this is the different
approach from the one that we took at
Google i/o the the talk in Google i/o
talked about let's track where the views
are here and let's set transient State
on all those views to make sure that
they don't get recycled when layout
occurs we don't care about that anymore
because we're using item IDs instead so
what's happening is the following for
all children that are currently in the
ListView and this is before layout runs
so there's no data set change yet the
list is just the way that it was at the
time that the user was swiping it we're
going to track where these things are
but so we want to know where the views
are but we're going to store that
information about position in a hash map
that's keyed off of the item ID instead
of the view itself right so for every
view we're going to say where are you
now we're going to get the top value
child get top we're going to find out
where it is in its container and we're
going to store that information to the
with the key of the item ID that's
associated with that view before layout
runs and recycle happens
and everything gets all confused in the
ListView but we don't care because we've
got the information we need item id
associated with position of the view at
the time then we're actually going to
remove the item and we're going to
remove it from the adapter that
automatically does a notify data set
changed and then we use a trick that's
common to a lot of my animation demos
which is we set a non pre-draw listener
so what's happened is we've removed the
item this is going to force a layout to
happen on the ListView views are
probably going to be recycled we're
going to chuck them out of the ListView
we're going to figure out where items
need to go then we're going to
repopulate views and who knows what View
is where we don't care because we have
stable IDs we're good to go
layout is going to happen and then our
pre-draw listener is going to be called
and this is the important point it's
going to be called before drawers happen
right so layout runs then it calls our
own pre-draw listener and then we can do
whatever we want and what we want to do
is set up an animation to animate views
from where they were in the previous
view in the previous frame into where we
want them to be now that layout has run
in the ListView is finalized all the
content for these views that change so
the on pre draw callback gets called
here where you remove the listener
because we don't care about it after
this one frame then we come in here and
walk through all current children of the
ListView right so this is everything
after layout ran everything got recycled
shuffled around for every one of those
we're going to say okay where are you
now give me your current top position
and if the position of that same ID so
I'm also tracking the the current ID of
this view and I know what the ID used to
be for that content before layout ran
and if we have a non null value for
start top that means that this view used
to be somewhere else in the container
and we're going to run an animation to
animate that change in values so if the
start if the the top position before
layout for this content is different
than the top position for for that item
after layout then we want to run the
animation so we're going to set an
initial
insulation y-value to basically run it
back to wherever it started from and
then we're going to animate to
translation Y of zero so we're basically
just going to animate it into place if
this is the first time it's running then
we want to with the first animation go
ahead and restore some values when we're
done kind of tedious to each other if
there is no starting position for that
particular content item then that means
that this view is just moving on to the
screen either from the bottom or the top
so we calculate an initial position to
start from and there's a little bit of
repeated code there don't worry about
that and then we come in here and we
again set the initial translation Y
value to that Delta and we animated the
animation code is exactly what we saw
before the only difference is
calculating the initial position for an
item that was previously off the screen
didn't exist in the ListView container
before and then when we're all done we
clear the top map which is where we were
storing these values of item IDs
associated with the top positions the
only other that's all the animation code
here the only other thing that's
interesting here is the background
container so there's kind of a graphics
optimization here where if we are
constantly drawing a background behind a
ListView where all of the items are
opaque then that means we're basically
getting overdraw we're drawing an entire
background and then we're drawing all
the items on top of that background
which is kind of a wasted effort if you
really care about animation if you
really care about performance and you
notice that you're getting bottlenecked
in some situations then one way that you
can work around this is to set a null
background on that container so that
we're not going to draw anything behind
it well that's a problem if you're
swiping out and you see into the
nothingness that's behind the ListView
so what we do is when we start doing the
swipe we tell the background container
to show the background that sets up some
initial values here so that we know
where to draw this this item background
and then we override on draw and say
okay well if if we're drawing this thing
then we'll go ahead and translate to the
open area and we'll draw our shadowed
background and our shadow background is
seen here this
is called from the constructors and we
simply load in this this resource this
is a nine patch the I defined it's very
simple it's basically shadow on top
shadow on bottom and then an area in the
middle it gets stretched and the net
effect which you can see in the demo is
that we have a little bit of shadow and
a little bit of shadow on top and a
little bit of shadow on bottom and then
this gray area in the middle so it makes
it look like all the items in the list
view are sort of popped out from this
virtual background that we have there
another item to mention is sometimes
when you're animating listviews if you
have dividers in the ListView and you're
sort of playing with things like we are
here like animating the translation
properties you may know that the notice
the dividers aren't necessarily getting
drawn correctly so I disabled dividers
so if you take a look at the layout for
application we have ListView divider of
null and a divider height of zero so the
ListView itself is not drawing dividers
and instead I've defined the textview to
actually use a divider so it's using a
backgrounds which I defined which is
basically all up a quite with a an
opaque line at the bottom of it and that
gives me my own divider that gets
animated along with these items as
they're moving around the ListView so
again this is ListView removal
animations it's the ability to animate
all the changes you could do a very
similar thing with adding I just only
took care of the one direction today but
it's doing it in a way that is usable on
all property animation api's all the way
back to when view property animator came
in which is 3.1 in fact you could use
object animator for everything and take
it all the way back to 3.0 and if you
want a little teaser in a future demo
we'll see how we can use a very similar
technique and actually run this thing on
gingerbread as well so check out the
talk at Google IO that we did on
animation called a moving experience and
download the code and play with it and
make your list views more dynamic thanks